sometimes i hear people talking and
they'll say well
you know
for instance black lives matter black
lives matter has cost thousands of black
lives it's gotten thousands of black
people killed their attacks on the
police have made the black neighborhoods
more unsafe children are being shot by
random gunman it's a nightmare what
they've done and yet they continue to do
it because they have an idea that it's
good if for a moment
it occurred to them that these
actual black lives that they are ending
with their policies are just as
important to the people who have them as
their life is to them maybe their
policies would start to seem less
important to them
so how do we connect some of what you
just said right there to politics
because as you were saying it i was
thinking man you know and i thought this
many times when i was on tour with
jordan that that rough message
basically is what we have to get across
to people to live more flourishing lives
and yet we're arguing about you know 3.5
trillion equals zero and boys or girls
and all of those things like we're not
even doing we're not even doing like a
semi-good job of connecting like meaning
to politics and that seems to me to be
the the biggest problem right now
man i can't i could not agree with you
more and i think you know the left does
do this they just do it for bad ideas
you know the left does make a moral
we're always sitting around with a
pointer saying you'll make much more
money and this like this ein rand
mentality where we think money is
everything is so untrue and it's left
our the people who want to follow us
empty and and wandering and the left
comes along and says no it's right it's
good to believe these stupid things that
we're telling you
to me
the the connection with politics and
there's no i don't believe there's a
there's christian politics i believe
that christian person can be in a in a
range of politics as long as he's not
oppressive and and dishonest and evil uh
he can have a range of politics but to
me at the core of christianity something
i call the the great speculation and the
great speculation is this that your
inner life is as important to you as
mine is to me that's the great
speculation and that's true whether
you're a garbage man whether you're a
homemaker whether you're a dancer singer
whatever you are
the speculation is that your inner life
is as important to you and as real to
you uh and as um urgent to you as mine
is to me and once you come to that once
you take that guess
first of all you begin to see that it's
true you begin to realize that people
have a right to be left alone they have
a right to live out the meaning of their
lives you know and
and when they when they do that when you
commit to that then you want them to be
free and when you want them to be free
you start to think well what are the
conditions of freedom you know obviously
some of the conditions of freedom are
you know have to do with morality you
can't murder people you can't steal from
people you can't uh defraud them you
can't lie about them these are those are
the ten commandments that's where they
come in you know these are these are
things that these are rules that are not
made so you'll be a nice guy you know
like don't do that or we'll punish you
that's not why they're made they're made
to liberate you so that you can be free
uh every one of the founders john adams
said it best but every one of the
founders said the this is a constitution
for a moral and religious people not
just moral but moral and religious
people and the reason for that is you
start to understand that the other guy's
freedom is as important to him
you know as yours is
sometimes i hear people talking and
they'll say well
you know
for instance black lives matter black
lives matter has cost thousands of black
lives it's gotten thousands of black
people killed their attacks on the
police have made the black neighborhoods
more unsafe children are being shot by
random gunmen it's a nightmare what
they've done and yet they continue to do
it because they have an idea that it's
good if for a moment
it occurred to them that these
actual black lives that they are ending
with their policies are just as
important to the people who have them as
their life is to them maybe their
policies would start to seem less
important to them and without religion
without that great speculation which is
a religious idea the idea that your your
neighbor is as worthy of love as you are
um without that
speculation it's so easy to get involved
in your ideas and
the goodness you know oh yes we must
bring justice and therefore we're going
to kill anybody who gets in our way uh
which is part of mar you know that's
another part of karl marx he basically
said yes terror and killing is fine as
long as you get to the place you have to
get so do you think then to that end
that people are believers whether they
believe it or not i think that's an idea
that jordan's been talking a lot about
lately and i've sort of come to that
conclusion that you end up saying no no
i'm purely secular i just believe in
this and we can just order society this
way but that in and of itself is a type
of belief that's then driving your
decisions
right because this is this is the power
of narrative there's another thing the
left knows about more than us you know
it's like we live in a time
when
it's uncouth to say
well you know let's let's see what god's
let's consult god let's see what god's
will is let's see if this is a a demonic
path we're saying we don't say those
things anymore and there's and there's a
good reason for it but that good reason
has become outdated the good reason is
science you know
when lightning used to strike they used
to think that demons were sending the
lightning so they would ring the church
bells to chase the lightning away that
meant the monk had to climb up to the
highest part of the church and ring the
bell and of course he'd be hit by
lightning and killed right and and when
benjamin franklin put a lightning rod on
top of a steeple it was much safer but
it also was kind of a symbol of a
materialistic philosophy that was going
to replace this spiritual philosophy and
now it's actually called the science as
if it were the wizard of oz you know
it's like because they come and worship
the science
for a while it made sense for people to
say oh
all of our speculations about
demons and about supernatural and all
these words that we don't like to use
anymore we're all wrong but that's not
true anymore science has now progressed
to a point where we see it's not
actually as mechanical as we thought
it's going to be it's kind of weird and
it shouldn't be here it looks by logic
by logic like life shouldn't be here
creation shouldn't be here we we
shouldn't be able to understand creation
and all those things are true and so
it's time we stopped doing that because
you're i think you're absolutely right
people believe whether they want to
believe or not and it's one of the
reasons that when you let go of that
belief people become evil you know they
they start to teach children to be uh
you know willing victims of pedophilia
they start to teach you about race those
are wicked things to do that's you know
these are wicked things to do because
they've let go of that sovereign good
that is the living god and
in a way if you listen to the way we
talk
we don't even say i was happy anymore we
say i had an adrenaline rush uh we we
use these materialist terms all the time
we don't say oh that's that's
right because it's obviously
right we always have these kind of
evolutionary explanations and you know
yeah so with some it's game theory and
also none of which makes any sense by
the way but leave that be that as it may
we eat we're all materialists and so
but and yet we know we don't live in a
materialist world we sense it we feel it
we're born with the knowledge of it uh
like i said there's no evolutionary
reason why we should know our fathers
should be just you know but why why do
we expect our fathers to be just and yet
when they are not just we know they have
failed at some essential task
so
we all know it but we have gotten caught
up in this narrative this materialist
narrative that i think is out of date i
just think i think people are living in
the in the 20th century
really and in the 21st century a lot of
scientific
paths have shown that they can't explain
this without a consciousness coming
first the only thing they have to admit
is that consciousness comes before
matter and and i think that's that's an
obvious truth you're saying i shouldn't
light my anthony fauci candle every
night before bed is that what you're
telling me he's not some sort of saint
that man the highest point if you just
want to watch him burn and melt
i can understand why you might want to
just watch him melt you know and say
that's for the dogs
what is it also what does that tell you
though about the psychiatr the
psychological makeup i suppose of groups
where it's like we see these people that
get so
much wrong
consistently and now we have the video
footage to prove it
fauci saying one thing about masks
publicly another thing to his friend
about oh no you can go on vacation and
don't worry about masks because you'll
touch your face more or the vaccines
mean we're going to open up now they
don't really work and you still can
transmit everybody knows the a million
examples that i can use here but but a
certain percentage of people keep going
to it they keep going oh well i forgot i
don't like is it a memory issue is it
like what is it what is it about humans
you know there's a line in dostoevsky
and i can't quote it from memory but the
line is something like
when you make people free when you set
people free their first order of
business is to find something to bow
down to
i think you know we're made to love god
we are made to bow down to god and i
think that um you know
after a while after you lived the
religious life for a while you start to
realize that all your attachments to
things and to p and to people are
pathways to god you know they're not
they're they're symbolic of the love of
god your love for your father's love of
god your love for your mother is the
love of the feminine side of god all
these things that you're looking for
that people fail you in
uh are because they cannot be the
perfect thing you're looking for beyond
them and once you attach yourself to
that perfect thing beyond them it
becomes so much easier to love the
imperfect people with their flaws uh and
forgive them for the the ways they can't
be what they can never be uh and and so
you know guys like fauci are there
because people are just desperate for
that thing and no one will give it to
him if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell